to live in an Amy world is to live in a
cozy community where would he come backs
good neighbors and spontaneous
appearances of dancers lit by fairy
lights are the norm what did it mean to
get to share this moment together to
present her with the Norman Lear
award I mean think God you talked a lot
about Norman Lear because those shows
meant the world to me growing up and
obviously this show has meant the world
to me as a grown-up and I could have
really hugged the entire evening
speaking my gratitude and and
reminiscing and it was just really fun
to speak in front of this group of
people but to also share the stage with
your lovely lady what did that mean the
one thing that I left out of my notes
and it's written down there so I can
prove it to you is I've said it before I
said it when you won't come in the room
for screening is that like literally my
life changed when she walked in the door
because there was no Gilmore Girls -
Lauren Graham existed and you know that
is a bond it's a weird like I I don't
know what my life would be without you
and it's the fans would say that about
the two of you guys because they are
still praying for more Gilmore is there
a chance what are you guys thinking
let's get through how quick she was and
I feel like a schmuck but I gracefully
like like a ballet dancer I told you my
metaphors are going to be very I mean
there's never you can you could never
say enough I'm just glad we continued to
be friends and lucky to have each other
yeah and I told her on the carpet but
you guys predicting that Marie Kondo was
gonna become such a big thing
I'm decluttering my life if it brings
you joy you keep it and if it doesn't
out it goes no joy he's taking the
dining room chairs they don't bring me
joy have you checked it out on that foot
oh yeah yeah yeah if I've seen the whole
thing I gotta say cuz she does we can
eat
any English so it's like this weird
mashup of like of like regular American
reality show and then she's like oh
thank you so much but it's through an
interpreter it's like with so many
levels it's wonderful I am endlessly
tight she's very neat I am Oscar she's
Felix
[Music]